[Music]
fantastic all right so here we are in
gorgeous day dance I hope you appreciate
the weather well and so let's just start
by you just introducing yourself a
little bit about your background and how
you came to be here my name is James
Leonard and I am an artist and I live
and work in Brooklyn New York but I'm
back up here in the Greater Boston area
with my current art work the tenth of
casually observed phonologies which is a
for lack of a perfect term it's what I
think people would call a performance
installation and this is a piece that
was begun back in February of this year
2015 when I was an artist in residence
at the Boston Center for the Arts for
four months as part of their program of
trying to encourage and foster the
emergence of new artworks that are
socially engaged art works my original
inspiration for this whole prediction
prediction X course now was over the
public would really understand what's
behind climate change simulations and
that they would take seriously the work
that's being done and that they would
think about their future much more
reflectively and that they wouldn't have
to submit these predictions as uncertain
when they hear the word uncertainty and
then what resonated so much with me
about your work and your project is that
you are also I think right trying to get
the public to think more about future
and divination traditions and climate
change and I'm just curious if you tell
us again a little bit more about about
how the creation of the tent and the
research that you did for this project
relates to the climate change this is
the research for me has really been a
process of discovery like and I'm coming
at this very much as an artist and a
humanist as opposed to a scientist or an
engineer and saying aha I'm very clearly
I have a clear path and I may be
actually giving scientists like putting
them too much I'm the I don't know on
the peg saying that you guys want to
know what you're after when you start
because maybe maybe you guys begin to
questions to me that's why we all
research over all and for me the the
first question that as well I was
working on another piece of media that
was another performance piece where I
was shaving a boat away into a sea of
shavings and this was in part a response
to the Arctic melt of 2012 which was one
of its the largest on record that we've
ever experienced and trying to relate to
my own sort of visceral emotions about
that that sense of the impermanence that
that showed the massive scale of change
and it came to me sort of as a dreamlike
images guys shaving a boat out from
underneath himself and so I was working
on that I was realizing that I was
working a lot in my relationship to the
past and the present and some long way I
was thinking about the future and I
think it started as a very cynical and
naive moment where I said well if we're
not going to listen to climate
scientists we might as well be listening
to fortune tellers and and at that point
I had a very very different relationship
to divination than I do now
fast forward a couple of years and I've
spent a lot of time actually working
with diviners of a number of different
traditions doing art works about
impermanence doing artworks about my
relationship to try to understand
divination and this side journey has
taken me into territory where I'm now
rethinking my my a lot of my own
original assumptions about divination as
something that I know I held what feels
to me sometimes in in vernacular
conversation with friends and colleagues
seems to be sort of a stereotype of well
divination is proto science it's science
that isn't quite right yet and when you
actually get computers to tell you the
answer and run simulations for you you
don't need it anymore or when you have
an accurate scientific theory you don't
need it anymore and instead I've started
seeing it as a cultural practice having
now then experience it both as a diviner
I'm giving readings inside of the tent
about climate change and experiencing
numerous readings myself receiving
readings and now as part of your
research by that was part of my research
process that's very very much to try
out the starting with the storefront
fortune tellers and then going into more
traditional religious and cultural
spaces that took a long time to get into
they're fairly close communities a
reading is made up of several things
several components there is there's a
diviner in the querent which is the the
person who does the reading and the
person who asked the question and the
reading itself begins usually with a
question or concern something that has
been brought and then there's often a
tool in between that will be your method
of divination sometimes that's an
internal method in some cases like the
people of our members of the
spiritualist Church will conduct seances
and so their method of divination is
happening from visions and things
happening with them I talk about that a
lot in the course about all the
different kinds of processes that people
use in that some people use random
processes in nature some people take the
more human spiritual approach and some
people use some kind of official
randomizing influence like a feral desk
or like a tarot deck or the II Ching
like flipping quarters to do the II
Ching or casting the arrow so don't try
all of those I haven't tried all of them
and there's several hundred existing
different methods of divination some of
which have been sort of lost to history
but there are echoes of them there's
lore of them and and I found that that's
sort of a side interest that I've
developed is just sort of the flavor
there's something about it that very
quickly as I was just even exploring
like say the Wikipedia and tree and all
the methods of divination it's it's so
long and a half the time it reads like
something from the 1960s conceptual
performance art pivot that for me like
really you know moved me like divination
by dripping wax divination by the tracks
of beetles divination by laughter but
the thing that all of these divinatory
experiences that I've had when when they
function well have had in common is that
they they create a space that does a
couple of things it creates a space that
opens up the mind for decision making
it's not it's not a substitute for
freewill that's one of the first
mistakes that I think a lot of modern
people who are unexperienced in
divination come don't you mean that it's
not a way to see a preordained future
it's also not a way to
you get a yes-or-no answer right and and
you know what I've what I've experienced
by being in your tent and talking with
you is that there really is this aspect
of getting people to think about their
alternatives and about possible futures
and about what they know about their own
future and you you were telling me
earlier that that part of the role of
the diviner is to get the querent to to
really talk and think openly and to be
in a space where they can can really
kind of have this experience where
they're focused on their own future and
where they sort of can see the world
around them but not really and and I
think that the space that you made
definitely accomplishes that and this
leads us to what the other main function
that I've seen in any of the successful
dignitary experiences that I've had is
which is um we're all taking in so much
information by the time you're 35 40 50
years old you have decades of life
experience if you're you know an active
participant in the Information Age and
you've read hundreds of thousands of
words you've experienced maybe you know
hundreds of academic theses and and
takes on something if you're an expert
in your field and how do you put all
those thoughts in order but what ends up
happening and and I believe we've used
this term before that divination can
function almost like as a comb for all
of those thoughts all that information
is taken in it's a way to sort of if you
think about the way a comb can move
through hair and lay it into line and
give it shape it's a way to take these
hundreds of thousands of different ideas
and start finding the natural shape
within it you know there's a story that
the V Carrasco week an expert on
Mesoamerican cultures told us I don't
know whether we had heard that story
already when I met you the first time
but he talks about the gods being
annoyed with the humans that the humans
on earth were learning too much about
the future and about the world and that
they took up a philosophical mirror and
that they breathed on the mirror to kind
of fog up the view that the humans have
but that nature around the human still
has all these hints about the future and
what's going on and that a lot of the
divinatory practices in
America have a lot to do with nature and
natural phenomenon and natural phenomena
and and the idea is that they're trying
to see past this fog and it's the same
kind of thing you talk about about the
forestry about but there's information
there
people just don't normally access in
their everyday lives and they're sort of
trying to find a way to access that
information and and you know you might
think that I as a scientist you know
wouldn't want to think about the world
that way but I think that there are a
lot of different ways to think about the
world and what you've taught me
really in talking to you is that just
like you said you know that you returned
with climate change a minute ago and and
you said you know that you thought well
we might as well just listen to fortune
tellers and when I started working on
this course I think that I was probably
pretty biased against this kind of well
just human reflection and what can you
learn about the future I don't human
reflection and I've really come to see
that you know I don't think you can
predict the climate 100 years from now
by human reflection but I think you can
get people to think about the future and
think about choices and so I'm curious
just to come back for a minute to
climate change how how has the reaction
been to this tent and how do you feel
you're doing in getting people to think
about the future and and and their own
futures with respect to the climate also
well just two days ago we were
exhibiting the piece in in the South End
of Boston and I was just finishing up a
reading and I overheard somebody outside
who was we had a little sign that sits
out in front of the of the piece that
lets people know sort of the general
house rules you know sort of please be
respectful for engaged and and this is
what we're doing and this is what the
piece was called you know so it sort of
helps put people in the right state and
have some instruction try to approach it
and there was somebody who just sort of
out loud said why would I talk to so why
would I talk to a diviner about climate
change and then somebody else wants to
go ask him and [ __ ] down all right
that's a perfect way to predict like the
short of it is is this gentleman walk
away not fully convinced that Tarot
works doesn't work but instead that it
made him look at everything that he has
already taken taken in himself about
climate change some of the grim
prophecies some of the hopeful stuffs
and stuff if they don't look at it
ignore it and
and juggle it just differently in his
head for the afternoon and and it got
him thinking about it and any even
remark that sort of as he left that Wow
that this is a great tool that is going
to stir or not but like just even this
way of like looking at this problem to
start digesting it because I think
that's one of the things that I find
that I want to make art about the
problem is it's so huge it's so
overwhelming I don't know I don't even
know about my fellow man just for myself
how do i buy to saw I know people who
will be part of the course later who do
the climate change simulations and who
do climate policy research and all of
this and they also feel overwhelmed and
I actually think that that what you're
doing is very important compliment to
making people sort of take the
perspective and look at the context of
all of the different kinds of
predictions about climate most of which
are not good we don't do anything but
that giving them a sense that there are
choices and that they can think about
the choices and that maybe they can even
learn something about the choices from
these you know somewhat time-tested or
ancient techniques you know from talking
to a lot of people about climate change
have you gotten a sense of whether
people respond better to maybe a
positive message or a negative message
and and how thinking more personally
about it makes it I don't think it's
actually the the fact that divination is
a personalized story since you are the
querent and you are starting to story
off with a question there's an instant
level of investment there and it's
tailored to you and and I think that
engages people differently that
personalizes it and sometimes people are
actually just even looking for
affirmation but they don't want just a
pat on the shoulder they want some sort
of external medium and this comes around
to one more third major benefit that
I've experienced myself and if they'd
have given divination as a cultural
practice whether it's connected to a
spiritual practice or not is um how it
helps us in a non-pharmaceutical way
deal with chronic anxiety like chronic
reality-based anxiety and and there are
times where I find myself saying losses
hat is going to happen but it doesn't
need to be absolutely
that even in and of itself helps people
make us people think about what that
mean and and it helps sort of either
step down expectations or get people
more on a realistic plane but ok it
can't be business as usual anymore but
where do we go it's been absolutely
fantastic and you've opened the eyes
inside
[Music]